[Musique]
est ce que vous savez ce que c'est la
smart itude peut-être que oui si vous
avez lu mon livre coécrit avec le
docteur georges nurdin sinon vous le
saurez à la fin de ce top tout le monde
ces sites est désigné les économies
émergentes par leur nom ou par leur
acronyme mais on sait rien ou presque
rien des entreprises de ces pays de
taille mondiale
on sait qu'en 2014 60 % du pib mondial a
été réalisée par les pays émergents en
2020 c'est à dire demain 70 % du pib
mondial sera réalisé par les pays dits
émergents ce qui est curieux c'est que
si les aspects de commerce international
ou macro économiques au sujet de ces
pays ont été largement capturé il y a
peu ou presque pas de travaux sur ces
entreprises qui sont le fer de lance de
leur stratégie est aujourd'hui de leur
principal avantage dans le commerce
international c'est la raison pour
laquelle il ya trois ans avec le docteur
george north d'un nous avons entrepris
une aventure vers cette terre incognita
un peu comme des explorateurs et nous
avons découvert beaucoup de choses
nous avons découvert un archipel qui
nous avons découvert une polynésie au
sens grec du terme une polynésie
d'entreprise d'entreprise atypique
d'entreprise dynamique d'entreprise
qu'on ne connaît pas beaucoup en europe
d'entreprises qui emploient des milliers
et des milliers de personnes à l'image
de vie pro en inde qui compte 156 1000
ingénieurs à temps plein des entreprises
comme mariko qui sont innovantes et qui
aujourd'hui est le l'oréal des pays
émergents des entreprises qui ont une
profitabilité et une croissance
à deux chiffres des entreprises qui ont
un chiffre d'affaires qui va de 1
milliard à plusieurs milliards d'euros
par an et on les connaît pas en europe
on les voit pas venir avec georges
burdeau nous nous sommes intéressés à
vrai dire principalement et en
particulier à la vague derrière la vague
autrement dit nous sommes aventurés et
nous sommes allés au delà des samsung
des tatars ou des lenovo pour aller
justement découvrir ces entreprises
dites émergentes ou nouvellement
émergentes qu'on ne connaît pas si je
vous cite le groupe
elle relève est ce que quelqu'un parmi
vous a déjà entendu parler ou connaît le
groupe
elle relève vous pouvez lever la main
une personne peut-être deux une personne
donc le groupe n roll elle c'est le
premier groupe privé aux émirats c'est
une entreprise qui a été fondée dans les
années 90 est une entreprise familiale
le chiffre d'affaires dépasse
actuellement 10 milliards d'euros
ils sont principalement dans la finance
la construction dans la logistique les
services l'éducation
donc ce sont des groupes diversifiés
si je vous cite un deuxième exemple
peut-être ce que j'aurais plus d'une
personne qui le connaît le groupe
d'un côté une deux super donc le groupe
d'un côté c'est un groupe aussi qui a
été fondée dans les années 90 par alico
d'un got qui est toujours le patron et
le président de ce groupe c'est le
numéro un en afrique premier groupe
privé africain qui a ses activités
historiques dans le ciment aujourd'hui
le groupe fait un chiffre d'affaires
2 17 milliards voire plus 10 de 17
milliards d'euros par an ils sont ils
ont tissé une véritable toile en afrique
est actuellement il se lance vers
d'autres continents à la conquête de
l'europe de l'amérique ou de l'asie donc
ces entreprises ont une spécificité
c'est qu'elles sont très diversifiés et
qu'elles se sont développées en un temps
assez court
c'est dire à quel point elles ont réussi
à se mouvoir avec la réalité
rapidement je voudrais faire un clin
d'oeil à deux entreprises
multinationales qui ont réussi à faire
des choses très positif qu'en france il
y as he makes une entreprise familiale
mexicaine et cevital qui est une
entreprise familiale algérienne toutes
deux sont venus en france elles ont
repris racheter des entreprises
françaises des fleurons parfois de
l'entreprise française qui avait déposé
le bilan et elles ont réussi à leur
donner un nouveau souffle et un nouvel
essor économique
cemex aujourd'hui sas à son style de
management qu'on appelle le cmec souhait
est étudié dans de nombreuses
universités aux états unis cevital est
également une entreprise qui maintenant
arrive à rivaliser avec les mastodontes
de l'agro alimentaire mondial donc la
philosophie du fondateur et commencer
petit voir grand et aller vite a
également réussi à maintenir de l'emploi
en france et à relancer un fleuron de
l'électroménager de notre pays
donc on pourrait naturellement se
demander qu'est ce que ces entreprises
ont su pu et voulu mettre en place pour
relancer ces entreprises c'est le
principal enseignement de notre
expédition vers la terre incognita c'est
la smart études
la smart étude correspond à cet adage
qui dit qu'il n'est pas nécessaire de
disposer des bonnes cartes pour réussir
ou pour gagner
ce qui est important c'est de savoir
jouer avec les mauvaises cartes
ces entreprises en tant que main de
savoir et de pouvoir construire avec la
contrainte et autour des contraintes
parce qu'elles ont trouvé racines dans
des pays justement où l'environnement
est très bureaucratique qu'il n'est pas
forcément favorable à l'entrepreneuriat
qui n'est pas favorable à l'innovation
qui n'est pas forcément doté
d'infrastructures de logistique mais
elles ont réussi à développer des
entreprises des outils de production qui
ont des avantages et qui arrive
justement à conquérir et réalisé avec
des entreprises des pays développés donc
on peut se peut se demander quel est le
point commun qu'elle est l'adn de ces
entreprises qui arrivent justement à
aller de l'avant malgré un environnement
hostile et bien la smart études c'est
surtout leur optimisme tous ces
entrepreneurs ses fondateurs ces chefs
d'entreprise que nous avons rencontrés
avec le docteur nurdin nous ont parlé de
l'optimisme
l'optimisme pour eux c'est cette
capacité ce prisme à diagnostiquer leur
environnement économique à travers les
solutions plutôt qu'à travers la
difficulté ou les problématiques
l'optimisme c'est le carburant
justement de l'énergie qui génère de
l'activité et qui créent de la richesse
cet esprit et est assez exceptionnel à
un moment où nous parlons de crise
mondiale où nous parlons de difficultés
ou parlant de récession
je pense que ce mantra des
multinationales émergentes qui consiste
à voir de la positivité en abordant les
sujets économiques
nous nous ferait pas de mal en france à
l'heure où justement dès qu'on parle de
sujets et économique on a une crispation
qui ce qui se crée qui se développe
alors s'il ya une leçon à retenir et à
apprendre des multinationales émergentes
au delà des données prospectifs c'est la
smart études
l'optimisme voir demain sous un angle
meilleur alors pourquoi pas dorénavant
avant de se poser sur des questions
économiques
d'abord se mettre en marche vers cet
optimisme est ensuite débattre de
manière plus est
les et sur les questions d'avenir je
vous remercie